I spent my interview yesterday,
but I didn't get the police investigation.
Well,
that's exactly what I was telling you,
is that in fact,
the assimilation interview of the prefecture,
him,
is mandatory.
Nevertheless,
the interview at the gendarmerie
or the national police is not mandatory,
unlike the mandatory police investigation.
So I explain,
be focused with me.
When you apply for French nationality,
we agree,
so far,
the prefecture,
she sends your file
to the gendarmerie or the national police,
it all depends,
uh,
of what is in your city of residence.
For 1 survey,
In most cases,
they call on the phone,
they take 1 little the temperature.
If you have 1 complaint against you,
This happens a lot,
you have summoned to the gendarmerie,
but don't worry,
it's nothing,
it's just 1 little.
You are laying small
to ask you small questions
like,
what do you think about equality
between men and women?
Uh, okay,
what is the motto of Françoise des for Covid,
1 French?
These are really basic questions.
But if we don't call you,
that's okay,
it's not mandatory
because the investigation can be done without your knowledge,
that is,
without your knowledge